a la izquierda Mineápolis 2020 George
Floyd y su No puedo respirar
a la derecha Memphis 2023 dairi Nichols
y un último grito mamá
casos diferentes pero una coincidencia
dos afroamericanos que murieron a manos
de la policía algo sistemático como
analizó para France 24 el activista
antirracista raudemar o Fungi dentro de
la misma policía sabemos que hay un
racismo sistemático pero a la misma vez
el mismo sistema lo involucra y los hace
cometer este este acto
en el caso de George Floyd el principal
responsable Drake showbing era un
policía blanco Eso desató la ira entre
la sociedad surgiendo el movimiento de
las vidas negras importan las protestas
antirracistas más grandes en décadas en
Estados Unidos en el caso de tariri
Nichols los policías involucrados igual
que la víctima eran afroamericanos
también su jefa y además esta comunidad
representa el 65% de la ciudad de
Memphis la pregunta que todos no hacemos
y todo se hacen o que todos los
comentarios dices Bueno pero fueron
cinco policías negros no fueron blancos
está bien pero el punto está que el
sistema policial de manera sistemática
entrena prepara y psicológicamente
prepara a policía para autodestruir Y no
y no defender
según el sitio web mapping police
violence en 2022 se alcanzó el récord de
los últimos 10 años con 1186 personas
muertas en intervenciones policiales
cada cuatro víctimas fue afroamericana
en este contexto el presidente Joe biden
Busca una reforma policial a nivel
Federal mientras 340 ciudades ya lo han
hecho un nivel local y seis estados por
ejemplo han restringido las órdenes
emitidas por jueces para que la policía
pueda entrar en un inmueble sin
notificación previa